so this is us moving in time and this is
prehistory and s is when we invented
writing and there was about six thousand
years ago now we are around here because
this is the long time of history we can
put around here the computer revolution
or as I prefer the information
revolution and with the information
revolution what we have is hyper history
we have inherited from the past a vision
of history divided in two halves the
first half is when a society of human
beings does not have the means to record
the present for future consumption in
this world normally means that we don't
know how to write and there are some
tribes in the Amazonian region which
still qualify as prehistorical as we
speak well then that particular group of
human beings is in prehistory that's the
first half then the second half is
history in history
technically speaking is again any stage
in human civilization when you have a
way of telling the future what happened
today we have used all the different
possible supports from animal supports
of some kind to biological support of
other kinds the papyri stones clay and
then paper and it goes all the way down
to the book revolution we have a third
stage at this point what has changed is
that not only can we record the present
and communicate to future generations
what has happened but our technologies
now can actually process the information
in question technology is always in
between is in between a user and
something else for example your sandals
are between you and the sand on the
beach this in between which is
technology here sometimes becomes an
in-between a user and another technology
that's the Industrial Revolution you
have a technology which is the engine
between you and some other technology
cogs and gears and maybe a car and
anything else now what happens when you
have a technology that can process
information for you instead of you what
it means that technology happens here as
well now we have a technology that can
interact with other technology which
interacts with other technology so a
computer can actually control a robot
which builds a car because is able to
process information autonomously the
user does not have to be in the loop may
not even be on the loop but it might
just enjoy the technology transparently
the technology there is like the perfect
Butler who will do anything for you
without even you noticing it and that's
the most optimistic scenario for some
pessimist actually we are being kicked
out of this loop and technology will
take over because the technology in
between will be governed by technology
in order to control other technology and
will take over I personally believe that
science fiction that is important to
take that into account in case you think
the science fiction has something to
tell us about the development of the
future for us one way of calling it
would be hyper history as in super
history even more historical than
history itself simply because during
history we have a lot of reliance on
written text you wouldn't have big
empires without laws written somewhere
instructions provided for for the future
and so on no Roman Empire no British
Empire no Chinese Empire without writing
today we are discovering that our
technologies which are processing the
information itself they are providing a
new sort of support for our life that
support has become essential and that's
why hyper history is also the time when
you can have cyber war in history
conflicts tend to be conflicts between
states national states I mean it takes a
long time for history to develop the
very concept of
national state sizing so Germany France
Great Britain United States but once
conflicts start involving ICT
information and communication
technologies then you don't have to have
a national state to have a war in a
conflict
ICTs is almost like hacking into a
nation's peacemaker is no longer just a
matter of fiddling with their
infrastructure it means killing that
other sort of the antagonist to the
opponent the enemy because if you are
for example managed to have access to
the electricity grid or the traffic
control system or the airport control
system or to the links between hospitals
if you have access to those kind of
infrastructures and you can hack into
those infrastructures in such a way as
to disrupt anything this normal life in
a particular country then you know two
things one that's a new way of
conceiving war and to that country lives
in hyper history because of course only
by living in hyper history you can
actually be armed by ICTs in nutshell
those who live by the digit they die by
the digit